bellissima notizia oggi abbiamo un
qualche cosa per skyrim
no scherzo allora e ho trovato il gioco
aspettate che lo compro in questo
momento allora esp e fa mi chiudo la
cartella eccoci god and liver pizza now
va bene salve ciao ragazzi tutta poi
come fa pesare 28 mag a che già solo il
pavimento sono 20 prendo posso sparare
pizzera entrambe le mani e tensione lei
l'ha mangiata già un sacco
va beh non fa niente gode liberty zona o
va bene vado e meno da te non me l'ha
data e vado io o la pizza nelle mani va
bene buongiorno serve oggi io le
consiglio un po di pizza che ho detto
ora quanto è contenta la mia pizza di
essere consegnata sopravvento bellissimo
lei è veramente bello lo sa please don't
but as o new york pizza riley miss my
dad ti manca il top aveva ben lacrima
strappa storia non mettere la noyes non
mettiamo il pesce sulla pizza fa
vomitare pesci subito noi preferiamo la
nana zagnoni qua buongiorno dove
esattamente il collocato il suo apparato
digestivo mi dica di qua sinistra
ragazzino comunque è bello perché è
sviluppato veneto gioco merita al prezzo
eco all'ananas eccolo io lo sapevo
ananas o morte preferisco la morte in
questo momento visto che si tratta anche
di pizza
io non rischierei di metterci la
smettiamo alle mogli scheletri salve
avete necessità di mangiare a posto
molto bene tutto vostro bellissimo
non so se sia possibile 28 mag a ciò è
veramente il gioco più leggero del mondo
salve ma lei è bellissimo posso
lanciarle un po di pizza per lei doppia
bellissimo contesto fantastico ragazzi
addio ai due denti non so se te ne sei
accorto ai due denti due soli permesso
sfondare con posso lanciargli un pò di
pizza dell'età ma come ma lei lei a due
facce dei ragazzi torniamo indietro
perché la parte della morte purtroppo
finita dobbiamo stare nella parte dove
c'è l'ananas io non so voi ragazzi però
nella vita ho sempre mangiato la pizza
bufala o patatine o prosciutto pugni
fantastica però io la pizza dicono sono
tante persone che affermano che la pizza
con la serata poi non fa schifo per c'è
persone che hanno sempre detto che fa
schifano poi detto ragazzi ma non fa
schifo in realtà io non voglio provarlo
cioè nel senso se mi mettessero avanti
una pizza grana se mi dicessero mangia
prova evitare che non fa schifo io non
riuscirei a mangiarla lo stesso pisa di
abominio non so spiegarlo sta roba prova
dovrà comunque io vorrei avere il suo
potere tutta la vita non voglio essere
superamento voglio l'invincibilità non
voglio l'invisibilità e voglio lanciare
la piazza cioè lanciare la pizza se non
avete superpotere migliore che una
persona possa mai avere nella sua volta
ruolo bellissimo di fare niente se non
lanciare la pizza davanti non riesco a
comprendere la scelta stilistica di
mettere delle alghe che spuntano dal
terreno quest'anno la capiscono sta cosa
però vabbè andiamo a dire grazie a
qualche parte porterà questo gioco
incredibile un centesimo permesso ci
sono due vie
andiamo nella via a destra mi sembra più
promettente ecco
salve buongiorno o dell'ottima roba che
vuoi un po dipende cosa intendi dio però
quella non è ottima roba creiamo un
abominio insieme ragazzi creiamo lo
bravo cioè io rilancio la pizza e
rilancia l'ananas la migliore steve cioè
praticamente è un generatore di ananas
feriti
ragazzi ma che roba allora laggiù c'è
qualcosa vedo qualcosa di strano tipo
umido non so cosa sia prova raggiungerà
no non sono gli ananas e del tizio che
io credo che ok invece di quasi roba che
ancora non ho visto andiamo favola per
la terra dell'ananas questa roba
permesso ma cos'è ma come la b ma come è
possibile non eccede la magia in questo
gioco incredibile cioè tu entri dentro e
c'è un posto che non c'è ma bellissimo
cos'è sta roba buongiorno avete del sud
e sabz scatole di pizza la media ecco
voi ragazzi un po per tutti reggono
cerifia ragazzi non c'e di che tu invece
la musica bruttissima ragazzina ma
perché lei è così piccolo credo di aver
finito pizza come si chiama suo gioco
tra l'altro non ho capito dei liberi
pizza credo di averlo finito
teoricamente perché non vedo altro
strano sono solo 28 mag a mi aspettavo
qualcosa di più avere che solo io prima
di concludere vorrei tornare dal tizio
su qua che sparava gli ananas che vorrei
capire un attimo che vita scrisse sta
facendo fratello mi dispiace per potere
più giusto andato a me però se ti lancio
un ananas non spani bizzarra è per caso
che ci ha sperato fino all'ultimo voi
voglio capire se continua a tirare pizza
crash al gioco ragazzi io ho fatto
sparare un sacco di hunan
mi sa che tra un po mi cresce al gioco
prova bene e stato bello allora ragazzi
vi porto un po indietro nel the seas lo
so mi sono tagliato i capelli fa strano
però mi in due settimane mi ricrescono
tranquilli volevo portarvi un po
indietro nel tempo da uno dei primissimi
giochi che io ho giocato il mio canale
su youtube in generale tratta proprio di
pizza pizza delivery ed è un horror
quindi switch subito sulla videocamera
loro bene quando io ho iniziato youtube
queste saturn i primissimi video adesso
dopo dario dare un'occhiata al quando
l'ho pubblicato l'ultima volta però
vabbè pinzari liberi ragazzi io sono un
vabbè o sono più di sopra vieni dentro
sarò giù in un minuto suona molto
maliziosa e pervertita questa cosa io
rimango qua signora stia pure lì no è a
parte gli scherzi
meglio mettere la pizza sul tavolo certo
prima cosa che mi è venuto in mente
promettiamo la pizza sul tavolo non
guardiamo poi il quadro inquietante
colui che si è mangiato al figlio però
va beh certo che lei ed i quadri non sta
ne sa benissimo sia signora è mancata la
corrente sono solo il pizzale liberi guy
fatemi uscire
cosa devo fare non mi ricordo niente che
non mi ricordo cosa dovevo fare ma
questa era la porta e non la vedo è
chiusa va bene non mi aspettavo
diversamente siamo qua a sondare gli
sopra non posso andare signora e
rimaniamo qui facciamo come premi mangia
la pizza a no ecco vengono signora
viscusi è non è che posso stati sotto
che c'è satana mi faccia capire ma lei
dove ma che a casa brutta che sa signora
se lo faccia dire oh mio dio
comunque io li comprerei dei lampadari e
signora no perché glielo dico un po buio
c'è il telefono posso chiamare aiuto
prenda questo telefono del 2013
she's not here fischi alla tiziano non
c'è però c'è la borsa di fattivo i soldi
eccoli eccoli lì perfetto il mio
carattere da moneygram bing hot money
for the pizza è in god the gucci borsa
ford e pizza too busy sbucci of disease
bancarelle di settimo torinese
ho i soldi della pizza quindi posso
uscire volentieri da questa casa magari
e 18 no non è di sotto
ho provato uscire ma la porta è chiusa
usciamo dalla finestra questa casa
orribile are you tear
ma chi sta suonando il telefono di sopra
al telefono vado a prenderlo mi scusi
brown da vodafone
[Musica]
e tutto questo solo perché ordinato una
diavola laica scuri cp soffitta come un
pezzo di pizza scritti che non so cosa
significava è una parola molto krypi
qualcuno parlava di mami e robe del
genere io vorrei uscire non si può
uscire
porca è chiusa chi è che ha parlato o
eccoti mi scusi eh la madonna cosa bella
zinne però adesso gioco e volete
veramente molto strano e non pendono lo
ricordavo così è chiuso è tutto chiuso
ve lo devo fare mainarda che dei pisani
mork il mio cuore non posso reggere a
lungo e meglio che smetta di muovermi
mio cuore morendo di infarto a non
camminare o morirai aspetta che il tuo
battito si calmi va bene
porca [ __ ] madonna che sarà proprio uno
spavento old style
ma come è vago e fini ma dai ma
veramente dai fratelli non me
l'aspettavo l'aspetto finale non mi
ricordavo signori questi erano i giorni
della pizza nel 2019 cosa è cambiato dal
niente però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
comunque è stato un po strano giocare a
sta roba non so perché anche perché il
gioco mega intelligente fatelo vedere i
vostri insegnanti i ragazzi fate vedere
cos'è la cultura
sto scherzando non fate niente di tutto
questo proprio vi siano cento ragazzi
iscritti al canale scherzo che mi piace
la campanellina prima della giornata
azione militare come sempre ci vediamo
al prossimo video ragazzi
[Musica]